So, when I decided to take a look at what websites had
a slow layout. I came to nbcnews.com. This website has different stories
laid out in sort of a grid on the screen. Let's see
what happens if we change the size of the grid. And, we
can see that the stories, instead of being stacked next to each
other are now stacked on top of each other. Let's make this
full screen again. And, we can see that the stories moved out
to their original horizontal orientation. Let's take a look at what this
looks like in Dev Tools. I'll Cmd+Option+i to open up
dev tools. Alright, where I have the HTML, let's go
over to the timeline. And, I'm going to hit the record
button, and start changing the size of the screen and watching
what happens with layout. We'll make it small. Okay, it
looks like the stories have moved. Let me go ahead
and make it full screen again. Cool. And, I can
go ahead and stop the recording. Alright. So, we have quite
a bit of data here in the timeline. I'm not
sure what we exactly we need to look at, so let's
go ahead, well instead of searching through, just filter out
what we don't want. Layout happens in Rendering, so let's get
rid of Painting, Scripting and Loading. We only see these
purple events here. Let's go ahead and take a look at
this section, we can see a few Layout events. Clicking
on this one we can see that it took 113 milliseconds,
which is definitely a noticeable amount of time.